hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the 2021 tata steel chess
tournament
in a game between jordan and van forest
and niels grandelius one forest has
excellent chances of winning the
tournament he's trailing to giri by half
a point
and if he wins and for example gary
loses his game
then anything could still happen so he
of course has every
bit of uh incentive to win the the event
uh but
glendale of course has something to say
about that so let's see what happens
here as i think we're gonna have a lot
of games to cover in the final round
because they're all
uh pretty crazy so when forest opens
with e4 we have c5 knight to f3
d6 and d4 so just a normal
sicilian defense we have captures
captures knight to f6
knight the c3 and a6 again we have the
night off on the board for i don't know
uh how many times in this tournament
already and here one forest uh
goes for uh the move carlson already
played against grandelus and that's
queen to d3
and carlson won that game very nicely uh
but of course probably after that grand
delus
came up with some ideas on how to
counter the queen to d3 idea so it's
very
uh very interesting uh how this game
continues knight
b to d7 uh we have bishop to e2
and now already with b5 uh we have a
completely new game
already as of move a so b5 is on the
board and now
uh jordan shows just how prepared he
came for this game and he plays
a4 which is pretty pretty great uh
considering knight the c5 will come with
an attack on the queen and the pawn this
pawn is already under attack and the b4
will just remove the defender so this is
a straight out pawn sacrifice already
from the start
so knight to c five by granddale is
going after the queen and
the spawn uh queen to e3 and now just
removing one of the defenders of the e4
pawn we have b4
knight to d5 and now uh grand daley
grabs this pawn
knight captures uh on d4 and now a5 so
very very nice preparation by avon
forest going after this b6 square he
wants to get this knight over there
uh and uh of course grandillus
eliminates it we have knight captures on
d5 queen captures an e4 and now
uh bishop to b7 could be played but uh
you don't really gain anything you're
not threatening any discoveries and the
bishop
uh will be undefended on b7 so first
defending the knight with e6
and now when forest castles we have
castles
bishop to d7 and now bishop to d2
uh we have bishop to e7 black also
prepares the castle
and the queen to f3 now making it a bit
difficult for the knights to move as the
rook would hang
so here castles uh and now just queen to
b3 now the knight definitely cannot move
and c4 is definitely coming so here
queen to b8
uh adding more defense to the b4 pawn
and the d6 pawn
and here we have c4 so the knight of
course cannot move the rook would
hang so uh b captures on c3 alpha song
we have b captures on c3 now again
preparing to push c4
so rook to a7 and here just rook after
b1
and the white has amazing development
for the price of only one pawn
so let's see what happens here we have
queen to c8
and c for now kicking the knight away
and this is where the magic happens it
doesn't matter where the knight goes or
do you uh
maybe even play e5 and try to trade off
the knights because whatever black plays
white's next movie is the same so here
black played knight to f6
but now feel free to pause the video for
the first time in this video and
try to find the move uh when four is
played while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
offering that knight without question
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's
knight to b5 and it's a very common uh
in the
when playing against the neither of to
either sacrifice something on b5 or even
offer something on b5
but i've never seen it done in quite
such a such a way and you have to accept
the knight
uh if you don't accept the knight for
example you play something like rook to
a8
then knight captures on d6 for example
bishop captures queen captures and yes
you pick up this c4 pawn
but what about the rook on a8 and white
doesn't even have to capture it right
away white can first
improve the position of the rooks for
example queen c8 rook c1
and only then capture on a8 and have a
completely winning position
so instead a captures on b5 was played
we have c
captures and now the two connected pass
pawns are just insane we've reached the
position from the thumbnail
and you simply cannot allow b6 b6 just
traps the rook and that's it
the bishop covers this the queen will be
covering the a6 square you have to do
something
and the only way to counter this is to
give up the bishop right away so bishop
captures on b5
we have queen captures on b5 and now
comes knight to d7
and this is again not the most optimal
way to play this
you kind of had to play d5 here to block
the slide square bishop
uh but here after knight to these or
even knight to d5
could have been played for example
knight to d5 and now you we would have
something like bishop captures e
captures and bishop to e3 going after
the rook but now
rook a6 can be played and then bishop to
d4 just not allowing bishop to f6
uh black still up upon but white is the
one who will be pushing however
after queen captures on b5 we have
knights to d7
uh but here uh grendel you missed one
very sneaky idea
so once again pause the video and try to
find this idea for white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting
the extremely paralyzing bishop to b7
also for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show and here black is really
without a good move queen to d8 was
played and now
a6 now completely trapping that rook and
the bishop to e3 is coming so what can
you do
to prevent this bishop from coming here
well you could go from knight to c5
or bishop to f6 first just attacking the
rook here
and now again an extremely interesting
position you could consider
giving up the rook with bishop to e3
which is very much playable
the problem is uh black will of course
not go after the rook if you just trade
off the rooks then captures captures
and after the bishop retreats this
bishop retreats and then just a7 a8 wins
the game
so what would happen after bishop to e3
is probably something like knight to c5
uh and then the rook still being under
attack you'd have to play rook to a2 and
then
queen to e8 offering a tree a queen
trade queen b6 attacking the rook and
queen to b8
and black sort of holds but it would be
it would be very interesting because
white will at some point
create some sort of a breakthrough so
instead of this
uh idea with bishop to e3 after bishop
to f6 by black
we have bishop to a five by one forest
now attacking the queen so of course
black needs to react to this
queen to e8 was played and now bishop
the c7
going after that d6 pawn which would
also go after this rook
so grandel used to grabs the rook on a1
it's the absolute best move and here
rook captures on a one by one forest
but there was a there was a better line
bishop captures and b6
is a bit more forcing uh point being
that now after the bishop
retreats for example bishop to e5 you
only then capture the rook
and now black uh has a lot of problems
because if you go for queen captures on
f8
uh for for example if you go king
captures on f8 then just
rook to c1 and you're in a lot of
trouble here with
this rook the c8 being threatened so
you'd probably have to capture queen
captures here
but then you will allow queen captures
on d7 and then
white just continues pushing this for
example g6 g3
and later on you can just bring the rook
into the game and it's going to be a
very very uh
difficult uh difficult position for
black to play
so this was in the position however van
forest uh
captured the rook on a1 and this allows
for a very very
good defense for grand delusions if
grandelus finds
knight to c5 point being that after
queen to b6 for example going after the
rook you have this queen to d7 move
and after queen captures on a7 queen
captures on c7
and black is defending because you've
given back the material you're going to
go after the bishop even rook to b8 is
the possibility
and you will eliminate that pass key a6
pawn
however after rook captures on a1 grand
delusion missed knight
to c5 he played d5 and now there simply
isn't all that much to be done here the
problem is
granddale you spent a lot of time trying
to work out everything that's happening
in this uh
preparation from one forest because one
forest is basically not even
spending time he has all of this
prepared so
bishop to d6 going after the rook here
this is the absolute uh
the absolute best and the situation on
the clock is when the forest is over an
hour and grand delus has only five
minutes on the clock
and it's only moved 29 they still have
11 more moves to make so
queen to d8 making some room for the
rook and now while you could capture the
rook we have
rook to c1 first just going after that
uh
queen to c8 idea uh look to see it idea
but let's just show what happens if you
capture if you capture
knight captures rook to c1 now again
you're going after the c8 square
queen to d6 and now we have to make some
breeding room for the king of course
g3 g6 black needs to do the same and now
rook the c6 grabbing hold of the b6
square for your queen and after queen to
e5 now queen to b6
but you have to calculate what happens
after queen to e1 check king to g2
now queen to e4 check king to f1 and now
after queen
to h1 check king to e2 queen to e4 and
king to d2 there are no more checks and
now white is winning
but that's a lot of checks to consider
and you don't want to uh
overthink your position and give grendel
use time to think
on your own time so first rook the c1
you can play all of that
once you've played rook to c1 so no
point in rushing that
and now g6 this was a very interesting
position because maybe rook the e8
was playable here uh since uh rook the
c8 right away is not a possibility
look to see it right away black will
happily capture that and after captures
captures black will have two rooks and
the knight against queen and bishop
and the black will actually be better
here he's also uh up upon for the moment
so uh maybe rook the e8 was not such a
terrible idea to consider but of course
white doesn't have to play rook to c8
white just continues mounting the
pressure
uh but okay after this rook to c1
g6 was played and now uh h3 white
also makes some breeding room for the
king even though just capturing the rook
right now
is definitely an option so h3 first
thing
you have no moves either way i can play
as slow as i want and now
rook the e8 here grendel you saves the
rook but now comes
rook to c7 and here uh white black is in
big problems because the knight is under
attack and
what do you do with the knight knight
the f6 was played but now
bishop to e5 preparing captures and if
the queen recaptures then the queen
captures the rook on e8 so here knight
the e4 was played
but now uh for the final time in this
video pause the video and
win the game for gandalius in the
simplest possible way
uh while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
finding an incredibly forcing line and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
it's queen to c6 you still attacked the
rook but now you're definitely
threatening queen to c8 so
not much black can do about this black
played rook to f8
but now bishop to d4 uh so just
attacking that rook and now what do you
play here uh there's no point in trying
to save the rook so
here queen to b8 was played but now not
in a rush to capture the rook we have
f3 kicking away the knight from such an
active square
and there really isn't uh much for for
black to do here any move you play loses
but here granddale shows why he's such a
very strong grandmaster because he finds
a way to to at least put up some
uh some resistance he plays the rook
captures on a6
and what do you play now if queen
captures on a6 then you
hang the rook on c7 so here bishop
captures on a6 is played
and now queen to b4 uh trying to trick
trying to trick white because here if
you go after uh pawn captures then queen
captures on d for check
and you will have a perpetual for
example king h2 queen e5
check you can play g3 but then queen to
b to check
and now the problem is if queen c2 you
can capture capture and yes
you're up a bishop but black has five
points you only have two and you will
not be winning this game
so very tricky this uh queen to b4 idea
but of course the bishop to e5
one forest doesn't fall for that we have
queen to e1
check king to h2 and now even knight to
f2 check preparing uh queen to h1
but luckily the white king has an escape
square
that is the g3 square so here queen c3
now is setting up a mating attack while
offering to trade queens because now
uh rook the c8 is coming and with the
bishop covering all of the dark squares
here
there is no escaping checkmate so queen
to h1 check king to g3
now even queen to g1 check preparing
knight to h1 to create a few more
problems for white
but rook the c8 now going for that
capture
and now knight the h1 with check uh if
if you go king to g4
then it's not going to be a win for
white you have to be very careful
because if you cap if you go here and
allow this to come with check
then king f4 and uh black starts at king
khan queen g3 check
king to e3 and now queen to f2 check
king to d3 and now queen to f1
with king c2 and now queen captures on
a6 and all of a sudden uh you're no
longer up any material if captures
captures
uh black now definitely has a fighting
chance he's even up three pawns so good
luck winning this
so instead after knight to h1 check we
have king to h4 the absolute strongest
uh
queen to f2 with check and now g3 the
bishop and king now cover the g3 pawn
but uh grendelius continues the king
hunt g5 with
check king captures on g5 and now how do
you continue you have to try and play
something
h6 f6 something must be played f6 was
attempted here
and now king to h6 it would be
incredibly
uh terrible if bishop captures on f6
comes
because then you are getting checkmated
you no longer guard the g3 pawn
and then after captures is just a very
nice checkmate captures
king g5 queen to f5 with check king h4
queen f4 check king to h3 and now queen
to g3 will be
checkmate so uh you have to be very
careful uh king the
h6 and incredible uh you know
it's uh i'm calling this a king hunt but
this is actually a king walk and
it's a very different thing when you
when you go for a king
king walk it's a voluntary uh you know
movement of the king a king hunt is
where
uh uh your opponent's king doesn't
really have a choice and usually gets
checkmated in the end so this is a king
walk not a king hunt
uh but okay f captures on e5 and now
queen captures an e5 also possible
instead of queen captures on e5
is just queen to c7 because there's just
nothing to be done here
after this one little check or queen to
e3 check
you can just play f4 and that's it there
are no more checks there are no more
tricks here
uh you cannot move the rook uh queen to
g7 will be checkmate on the next move
and that's
it so uh queen to c7 was a possibility
when forrest played queen captures an e5
a simple a similar idea
going for the same checkmate you don't
really care about the rook here
this check again is met with f4 there's
no way to go around this
so here uh we have uh queen to e5 and it
was in this position on move 47
after reaching time control uh that nils
granddale used to resign the game and
jordan one forest
wins one of the most beautiful games in
the entire tournament
uh and uh well we'll see if it is enough
for him to win the tournament because a
lot is still happening alireza is still
playing
fabi still playing uh geary is still
playing against david anton and
that game is also quite impressive uh
the carlson
uh mvl game also already finished it was
also a masterpiece so
we're gonna have a lot of fun covering
all of those for for today and tomorrow
but now let's uh continue with the
tournament so hope you guys enjoyed this
uh really really awesome stuff by
jordan von forrest i would like to thank
kd nuggets carlo coso
mohit diaz jeff norris and aditya suresh
kumar for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the tata
still checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day